MIHAI IONESCU: Hey, guys.
We're back with another session
of Segments Live on
Google Developers.
Today we're going to have an
Office Hours style session.
We got a lot of questions on
Moderator and in the Groups,
so we're going to try to answer
as many as we can.
But first, let's start to make
a few announcements.
PENG YING: What's
going on, Mihai?
MIHAI IONESCU: A lot of
stuff is going on.
Last week we told you about
Google DevFest.
The West Coast edition is going
to happen this weekend.
And I'm going to switch
now to the screen.
If you guys signed up, great.
Unfortunately, it looks like
we are sold out for the
Saturday and Sunday events.
PENG YING: Oh, it's sold out.
What's going on?
Can you tell them a little bit
more about DevFest and what
we're trying to accomplish?
MIHAI IONESCU: It's going to
be very cool this weekend.
We have a lot of talks
on Wallet.
We have talks on various Chrome
APIs, Code Labs, so if
you signed up, you're really
going to enjoy it.
And of course, there's
going to be a party.
PENG YING: Nice.
I love those parties.
MIHAI IONESCU: That's what
I'm looking forward to.
PENG YING: I think people are
just coming for the parties.
The Code Labs, eh--
no, I'm just kidding.
It's a great way to
learn more about
different technical aspects.
MALE SPEAKER: We noticed that
your computer is not sharing
to [INAUDIBLE].
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
Oh, so we'll fix that.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's make sure
you're fully mirroring
before we continue.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
PENG YING: [INAUDIBLE] out.
So how does it look?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, what we
could do, we could run the
[INAUDIBLE] again
and start again.
PENG YING: Well is
it mirroring?
MALE SPEAKER: What we're
seeing, we see your
background.
We don't see the rest of it.
PENG YING: Oh, it's
not mirroring.
It's doing the--
MIHAI IONESCU: It's on--
PENG YING: No, just-- it's--
do you have the mirror
up here?
MALE SPEAKER: Just say, for
everyone who's listening,
we're going to take a
couple of minutes.
MIHAI IONESCU: How about now?
Is it working?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yes,
we're good.
MIHAI IONESCU: OK.
So let's keep going.
Slight technical delay here.
PENG YING: Technical
difficulties.
[INAUDIBLE].
MIHAI IONESCU: It happens
when you're live.
But now we're good.
So I just talked about
the Dev Fest West.
We're sold out, but for those
who signed up, we are looking
forward to see you guys.
And the other announcement--
we keep on mentioning
every time--
but we love people who are
passionate about APIs, and
we're hiring in the Developer
Relations Team, in the Wallet
Team as well.
So if you're interested, you
want to play with the latest
and greatest, check out the
Developer Relations Jobs page
and apply for advocates, program
engineers, program
managers, wherever you feel you
can make the most impact.
PENG YING: And the URL is
developers.google.com/jobs.
We're really looking for a few
new folks to help out.
So please apply if you're
interested.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
Let's move on to
the questions.
Lots of them, very
little time.
PENG YING: Yeah, so--
MIHAI IONESCU: Do you want
to take the first one?
PENG YING: I will take
the first question.
And the first question is--
it's related to right
now Google
Wallet deals with goods.
It's "How do I verify that the
JSON web token I create is
correct?" And first, let's
talk about what a
JSON web token is.
It's a method to ensure that
content you send over to the
client's browser hasn't
been altered when you
go through a purchase.
So the way that we do it is we
append a signature to the end
of a body content.
So a JSON web token consists
of three things, a basic
C4-encoded header appended to a
content body, appended to a
signature, all concatenated
with periods.
So in order to ensure that the
JSON web token you create is
correct, what you can do is
you can take the content
between the two periods and
then Base64 decode it, and
then take a look at that
JavaScript Objects.
You can also use our JSON
web token decoder.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, I'm going
to put it up on the screen
right now so you guys
can see it.
It's on the documentation under
Resources Tools, a very
useful tool.
PENG YING: With this tool, you
can just copy and paste the
entire JSON web token that
you've created, and then this
tool will decode the main body
using the technique I
described earlier.
It does some additional things,
like HTML encoding, or
HTML decoding, so if your
slashes or something are
incorrect, it'll automatically
correct that for you, which
isn't the best.
But there are caveats to it.
But If you really want to ensure
that the content's
correct, what you can do is you
can open up the Developer
Tools in Chrome and then go to
the Console and use atob,
which will convert your
Base64 string to
just a regular string.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
So the next question--
I'm going to take the next one--
looks like it's somewhat
related also for the
digital with API.
And the question is, "I get the
following error message on
an [INAUDIBLE]
request." And the message is,
"We could not complete your
purchase because of technical
issues." "How do I figure out
the problem?"
So the first thing you do when
you get something like that,
you check the error codes that
you receive in the client
failure handler.
So that's a client-side handler,
which will be called
when the payment fails,
the transaction fails
for whatever reason.
And I'm going to put up on the
screen, again, the reference
to those error codes.
So if you watch the screen now,
you will see that we have
four error codes in the Error
Type field that will give you
an indication of what
went wrong.
So the first three are the most
important ones that you
should bluelight.
For example, Merchant Error
will tell you that the
purchase request contains an
error, for example, a badly
formatted JWT that my colleague
talked about earlier.
You can use the decoder, see
if one of the field is an
incorrect format, fix
that, and move on.
The other two are Purchase
Canceled, either the buyer
cancelled the purchase
or there is a
payment declined error.
Not much you can do there, but
it's a good indication where
the problem is coming from.
And the third one is Post Back
Error, which means you failed
to acknowledge the Post
Back notification
sent to your server.
You have 10 seconds
to do that.
Otherwise, the transaction is
automatically cancelled.
So check that you received the
Post Back notification.
Look at your logs,
and make sure you
respond in 10 seconds.
And finally, the last one is
Internal Server Error.
It can happen.
It seems it means something
went wrong on Google side.
If you see that, let us know in
the forum, and we'll help
you debug that or check
if there's something
wrong on our side.
PENG YING: Cool.
So I'll take the next one.
It's a question from a forum
about recurring subscriptions.
"When is a subscription first
and second payment charged?
I'm confused about the phrase
'you'll be charged at the end
of the billing period starting
on.'" Yeah, so I guess we want
to take a little bit of time to
clarify the billing cycle
for recurring billing.
The first subscription payment
starts on the start date that
you set in the recurring item
in the JSON web token.
Well, depending on how
you schedule your--
how you create your recurring
item and your initial payment
inside the JSON web token, the
first payment is taken at the
time the customer purchases,
which is that
initial payment segment.
And then the recurring billing
starts at the start date that
you set within your
recurring item.
So those are the two
differentiations.
The second payment will occur
one month after the start
date, exactly one month after
the start date, and
so on, and so forth.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, so it's a
little confusing statement.
And I think we're working
on making it better.
Because there are a lot of
technical terms there, and
probably it's not the best.
PENG YING: Yeah.
Subscriptions are a
confusing thing.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right, I'll
take the next question.
It's related to Google Wallet
Mobile, so we're switching
gears a little bit here.
And the question is, "Does
Google Wallet Mobile require
an internet connection to
authorize a payment at an NFC
reader?" And the answer is no,
it does not require an
internet connection.
It will work 100% without
a data connection.
And this is a big misconception
that you'll
always need to be online, either
wireless or on your
carrier network, so you
can make a payment.
It is not required.
All the phone is doing is
transmitting your card
information to the reader.
And then the reader voice
processing the entire
transaction.
So all you have to do is enable
your phone, tap, and
you're good to go.
PENG YING: Yep, simple.
MIHAI IONESCU: Very simple.
PENG YING: OK, I'll
take the next one.
"I'd like the ability for users
to purchase physical
goods with Google Wallet
inside my app.
The in-app purchase API cannot
be used for this purpose, as
it is restricted to
digital goods.
What API should I use?"
So right now, for--
I'm guessing they're talking
about web applications and not
Android applications.
Or what do you think, Mihai?
MIHAI IONESCU: Oh
yeah, let's see.
So it looks like he's mentioning
it could be either
an Android web application or
an Android application.
In either case, physical goods
are not supported at this time
on mobile apps.
You could use the
Checkout API.
Right now, that's your
only option.
But that is only available to
merchants in the United States
and the United Kingdom.
So there's a big limitation
right there.
The good news is that we are
working on expanding the
current Digital Goods API to
support physical items.
So that will come,
and it'll also be
available in more countries.
PENG YING: There's a few
different payment method APIs
that we're currently
working on.
And then these are geared
towards physical goods for
mobile or for the web.
Should I take the next one,
or do you want to
take the next one?
MIHAI IONESCU: I can
take the next one.
PENG YING: OK.
MIHAI IONESCU: So the next
one also related to
Google Wallet Mobile.
The question is "If I lose my
phone, how can I prevent my
Google Wallet Mobile from being
used to make payments?
What other security components
are part of
Google Wallet Mobile?
So it's a very good question
and a question
that comes up regularly.
There are lots of protection
layers to prevent
unauthorized use.
First, you have two layers
of passwords.
The first one is your
Android screen lock.
You have to turn on your screen
in order to enable any
NFC type of payment.
And then unlike leather wallets,
you have an extra
four-digit Google Wallet
pin that prevents
unauthorized access.
So that's the first layer.
The second layer, if your
wallet ever gets lost--
your phone wallet-- ever gets
lost or stolen, you can
remotely disable it.
And that would prevent
any unauthorized use.
Your credit cards will continue
to work normally.
It's just your phone is
completely disabled right now.
And other security enhancements,
we can mention
encryption, the debit and credit
cards you store are
stored securely online
in the Cloud.
They're not even on the phone.
On the phone, you use
a virtual card.
So your credit card numbers
are not even
passed to the merchants.
So there are lots of layers
that prevent any type of
unauthorized use.
PENG YING: All right, I guess
the next one I'll take.
MIHAI IONESCU: You'll
take the next one?
PENG YING: "What advantages does
Google Wallet Mobile have
over making a payment by swiping
a credit card?" I
think there are a few different
advantages.
One is simplicity, I suppose.
What happens when you tap to
pay is that multiple things
are transmitted.
So for merchants who accept
it, it will also transit
things like loyalty cards,
offers, and then possibly any
clipped coupons that
you've stored.
We hope that Wallet will, in
the future, enable you to
store more things within
the Wallet.
So like we were talking about
previously on one of our
Google Developer Live sessions
is that the idea of storing
maybe a transit card in the
Wallet or something like that,
tickets, and so on,
and so forth.
So we hope that it's a thing
of convergence and it
simplifies the user's life.
In addition to that, it's
pretty convenient.
So instead of carrying maybe
your loyalty cards, your
credit cards, your gift cards,
your whatever else that you
may store in a Wallet, you
can all have it digitally
represented within the phone.
And it's much more--
the space isn't as large
of a concern because
everything is digital.
And the last thing
is security.
As Mihai previously mentioned,
it's much more secure than
your physical device.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, and less
worries if you lose it.
PENG YING: Yeah.
MIHAI IONESCU: Cool.
Next question, "Can you
demonstrate using a phone to
make Google Wallet mobile
payment at an NFC reader?" We
don't have an NFC reader
here, but we can demo.
We have lots of videos--
PENG YING: YouTube.
MIHAI IONESCU: That show
it, how it's done.
So I'm going to switch to my
computer now, again, and I'm
going to launch a video here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PENG YING: I don't know if HTMI
gets the audio out, but--
-With Google Wallet--
PENG YING: We'll--
-You can pay with your phone
at hundreds of thousands of
merchants with any
card you want.
To get started, select
your card--
MIHAI IONESCU: Pick a card--
-Visa, MasterCard,
MIHAI IONESCU: Any card.
-Or Discover, credit or debit.
If you don't see the card you
want, it's a snap to add
another one.
All your payment info is
encrypted and stored securely
in your Google account online.
And with Google offers that
automatically sync to your
phone, saving is simple.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes, coupons.
-Let's say you're buying
a smoothie.
Just tap the back of
your phone on the
terminal and that's it.
A confirmation screen will let
you know you're good to go.
Enjoy your blended beverage.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PENG YING: Cool.
MIHAI IONESCU: Wasn't
that great?
Tap and pay, and then
enjoy your smoothie.
PENG YING: It's the future.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes.
And you guys see the
page I just put up?
It's very useful.
If you go browse it, you can see
lots of merchants that are
accepting Google Wallet.
And if you want to try it, just
go ahead and go to one of
these merchants, buy
something you like.
PENG YING: Yeah.
I'll take the next question.
"How are payments by Google
Wallet processed?
Would a bank charge me
a fee for using it?"
So the way that Google Wallet
works right now, as Mihai
mentioned, that Google provides
a one-time card for
the merchant to process.
It's a prepaid MasterCard debit
card, I believe, so that
when the merchant processes it,
they just go through their
typical merchant processor
or a merchant gateway.
So as a user, you
incur no fees.
And as a merchant, you would pay
the typical fees that you
do to your credit-card
processor.
MIHAI IONESCU: And if I can
add, a lot of questions on
security or related to what's
just been asked right now
about fees, the answers can
be found in our FAQ page.
I'm going to put up again the
page so everyone can see it.
It's one click away,
google.com/wallet/faq.html,
and lots of good
answers to most
frequently asked questions.
So if we didn't answer something
on this session or
not to your satisfaction,
please go
check out the FAQ page.
And with that said, let me move
on to the next question.
Oh, it's an easy one.
"How do I know if a payment
terminal will accept Google
Wallet Mobile?" So
very simple.
I'm going to put the
page up again.
Look for the PayPass sign.
You can see it right there--
PENG YING: Yep.
So we're using the same
communication protocol that
your credit card uses, that your
MasterCards use, PayPass.
MIHAI IONESCU: So if you see the
PayPass sign, you can tap
your phone and pay.
PENG YING: Yep.
I guess I'll take the next one.
"Can I attach a debit
card to my Google Wallet
Mobile?" Yes.
Now, because we're aliasing the
credit card and providing
a one-time card to the merchant,
you can actually add
any type of card to your Google
Wallet and use it at
any store that can accept
payments through PayPass.
So you can add debit cards.
You can add Discover.
You can add MasterCards,
anything that is in your
wallet as a method of payment.
Or I would say not anything,
but most things that are in
your wallets as a method of
payment, you can likely add to
Google Wallet.
MIHAI IONESCU: Just right,
most likely will work.
PENG YING: Yeah.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
You just saw the demo
video before.
It had the credit card
or debit card screen.
Just try, see what works.
On top of that, if I can add,
you are able to add your gift
cards to the phone.
So that's great.
Macy's, Bloomingdale's,
you name it.
You get a gift card.
Put it on the phone.
It will be there.
You're not going to lose it.
PENG YING: A few gift
card partners.
Some stored value.
MIHAI IONESCU: And
very convenient.
OK, let me take the
next one, another
security and risk question.
"Is any information
stored at risk?
How is the user protected?"
So I think we covered it
in a previous question.
To recap, linked credit or
debit-card credentials are not
locally stored on the phone.
They're in the Cloud.
The merchant will not get
your information.
If your phone is lost or stolen,
there is no fear that
your information
is compromised.
You can remotely disable it.
All kinds of security layers
that protect you.
PENG YING: Yeah.
I guess I've got the next one.
MIHAI IONESCU: Take
the next one?
PENG YING: Yeah.
So "Does Google Wallet Mobile
work on the Nexus 7?" And the
answer to that is yes.
It should be working
on Nexus 7.
MIHAI IONESCU: A
resounding yes.
PENG YING: Yeah.
I would hope that it works
on our own device.
MIHAI IONESCU: If it works,
it works on all devices.
PENG YING: Yeah, so there's
an FAQ that-- do you
want to show the FAQ--
of the list of devices that
Wallet is supported on.
And if we can bring that up--
MIHAI IONESCU: Let's see.
So if you can see my screen,
then actually I think we go to
the Help Center, which is at
the bottom of the page.
And in the Help Center, it
should be Eligible Devices.
So you see here on the left
side at the bottom of the
navigation sidebar, we
click on Eligible
Devices, and it's in there.
The Nexus 7 Tablet.
PENG YING: Nice.
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah, I think
it was available the moment
the tablet shipped.
And to come back to a previous
question, now that the tablet
is Wi-Fi only, you don't even
need Wi-Fi to make a payment,
as we said.
Any Google Wallet payments do
not require any connectivity.
So I think you are somewhat
related to this aspect.
So just take your Nexus 7
out there and buy stuff.
And this is the list of devices
currently supported.
PENG YING: I think you get
the next question.
MIHAI IONESCU: I'll get
So actually, let me see.
We have quite a few questions
about international
availability, and we get
them every session.
And the answer is invariably
we cannot make any firm
announcements at this time.
But we can point you to the
newly launched Google Wallet
page on Google+.
It has a lot of timely
announcements and a lot of
discussion on these topics.
They are much more frequent
than our biweekly session.
So please check it out.
And that's the first place
you're going to hear about the
new launches and availability.
PENG YING: Yep, social media,
it's taking over.
I guess I'll take
the next one.
"Does a transaction using Google
Wallet Mobile look any
different than a credit-card
swipe to the cashier?" Well,
other than going up to the
PayPass terminal and then
tapping your phone, the
transaction should look
identical in the sense that if
you were to take a credit card
and tap it, the credit card
transmits on the pin, the
[INAUDIBLE] number, or the
account number, to a terminal.
And then you would be able to
process it normally like that.
The phone is doing
the same thing.
So it's riding the same
payment rails.
And to a cashier, it should
look like the same flow.
MIHAI IONESCU: They may
be a little surprised.
PENG YING: Yeah, like,
what's that, a phone?
MIHAI IONESCU: It's magic.
What did you do?
PENG YING: Can you
do that again?
Can you make a few
more purchases?
MIHAI IONESCU: Yeah.
Did you really pay?
I'm not going to give
you your stuff.
So that's fun.
I would say I experienced that
with merchants, and they were
really amazed of how fast it
was and how convenient.
And yeah, go try it.
I'm sure you'll have fun.
I'm looking at a couple
of questions which
are somewhat related.
The question is "How will a
store handle a Google Wallet
transaction if they require a
signature?" And the second one
is if they require
to see the card.
So generally, stores are asking
you to see the card and
the signature to make sure the
card is signed, to make sure
you sign with the same
signature, to double check
that the card is not
a duplicate or
a compromised card.
So none of this really applies
when you make a payment with a
mobile device.
Your card is already
stored in there.
It is saved in the Cloud.
There is no reason if the
transaction goes through for
the merchant to check the
physical card or the signature.
So I think those are corner
cases, and probably the
merchant is not educated.
PENG YING: Well, I think before
you can enter in a
card, you have to enter in some
identifying information
associated with the card so that
Google Wallet can ensure
that the card belongs to you.
It's pretty minimal information,
but it's to know
your consumer and make sure that
it's not a stolen card
that we're adding
to our network.
MIHAI IONESCU: So the security
check already happened.
The merchant is protected and
doesn't need to actually check
your physical signature.
PENG YING: Yep.
MIHAI IONESCU: All right,
getting closer to the end.
Let's--
PENG YING: Should I take
this last one?
MIHAI IONESCU: Yes,
let's do that.
PENG YING: All right. "Does
Google Wallet Mobile protect
me against unauthorized payments
the same way my
credit card does?" Because we're
using your credit card
as the back instrument, you
should receive the same
protections--
you would receive the
protections that your credit
card provides for you.
We're simply putting an alias
card in front of it, or
putting a one-time card in front
of it that is backed by
your card, which means that all
payments will eventually
end up on your card.
And we're working--
or we have ties in place
to ensure that this
kind of stuff happens.
So yes, you will be protected
against unauthorized payments.
MIHAI IONESCU: So again, lots
of good answers to questions
on the security, privacy,
and merchants
are in the FAQ section.
So if something we
didn't answer,
please go check it out.
All right, we got close
to the end.
Thank you, everyone, for
submitting questions.
PENG YING: A reminder to if
you signed up for DevFest
West, we'll see you
this weekend.
And then be sure to check out
developers.google.com/jobs for
information about our
jobs availability.
We hope to see you next time.
MIHAI IONESCU: All
right, bye-bye.
PENG YING: See ya.
[MUSIC PLAYING]